I think the thing that I did that that
worked out for me best was I just
stayed patient and I never.
I never took the the you know, they
dangled a carrot in front of your face,
you know what I mean? Or whatever the
thing is. Like, I never took the never
went after.
The shiny object.
Exactly. Meaning like.
I just always felt like I was always
hesitant to do what was being offered.
You know what I mean? Although, you
know, for instance and I think in in
rap or maybe it's music, period, but
like, you have a successful album.
They want to renegotiate right away.
And the artist is like, Yeah, I'll do
that because you're going to get
another million. But they want to
renegotiate. But it's like they're
going to tack on how many albums for
that. So it's like I was like, Oh, I
got these successful albums, I'm going
to chill. I'm not going to just
renegotiate. I'm good on that.
Boom boom. And the longer I waited, the
better my leverage played out for me
when it came time, you know, it's like,
no. And I still apply that to this day.
I'm like, I'm very slow to do those
types of deals because I'm like, Yo.
I don't know yet. Let me fill this out.
You know what I mean? Let me take a
little more time. And the more time you
take, the more the more the truth
starts to show itself.
You know what I mean? It's like. So I
can't really sit here like some mogul
and give business advice because I
don't I don't think I run like the best
business. I'm grateful to have great
people around me where it's like my
money. Good boom, boom, boom.
You know? I mean, I'm smart with my
money, You know what I mean?
Like, I've always been. And that just
comes from fear. It's like I don't
never, ever want to be broke again.
So I'm slow to, like,
Frugal or.
Or just mindful, which one?
What's the difference?
Frugal means you don't spend shit
because you're a cheap ass.
Mindful means, yeah, I'll splurge.
I'll treat myself. There's things that
I do know. Yeah, I would.
Definitely say mindful because if it's
the right thing, if it's a vacation,
you know what I mean? Family vacation.
I'm going to spend, You know what I
mean? Like, if it's a if it's a no, I'm
not afraid to spend. But but I'm
mindful where it's like, yeah, I think
mindful is the word, you know what I
mean? And it helps that.
It's like, I don't. I don't.
I'm not I don't really like I'm a hard
person to get a gift for because I
don't it's not like I have everything.
I got every car, boom, boom, boom.
It's like if you got me a car, I would
be like, Oh, man, he got me a car.
You know what I mean? Like, he don't
know. I don't care.
about cars. I don't really care about.
Yeah, like, man, you know what I mean?
Like, oh, like you got me a watch.
Like, damn this expensive watch.
I appreciate it.
Like, it's going to put it up.
Yeah.
And my heart, I'm like, bro.
So it helps that I don't really.
That allows me to go a little harder
over here, you know?
Yeah. Remember I caught you with the
socks? You just had the.
Remember you had the socks out the
pack, and I was like, J What?
There they go. God damn, God damn, He
was on me.
You know, I think about you often.
God damn, I wear these socks.
These, like. Like yellow toe socks, bro.
I just had to take them off to keep it
real, bro. Like we was.
We was shooting a video.
Kevin seen my socks and he.
And he was like, I remember.
You was like. You know there's better
socks, right?
I remember I had a suit.
I looked at you because I was like.
Yeah, you know that.
You know, there's a higher level.
You get a better quality sock than that.
Like, I know where that sock is from.
You're like, I like these.
You just kept. I remember you kept
doing this. I like these.
Like you. Just so I know.
Those are the ones that's like six in a
pack, right? Yeah, I think so.
Yeah. What do you spend it on?
What's the splurge? Okay, a vacation.
What is the. What?
Is that it? Yeah. You got, like a
stupid video game set up or some shit.
No, no, no.
No, no. But I'm about to get that.
I just got into the VR.
The VR?
I can see. I can see. I'm gonna set that
up. Your house. You got a room?
Put these on and step into, like, a
suit. What else? There's got to be
something. What's the thing?
Um. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Like on a I mean, on a consistent basis
or like.
I built a.
Studio. A studio in the crib. But that
was a lie. Okay?
I mean, that's good.
I got a gym at the crib.
That's good. All right, So those are.
Those are like. Personal growth spaces
in both of them, things like that.
You're you're investing in the things
where you can get a return out of the
studio and the house is dope as hell.
Whenever I want to go down, I can go
down. I'm in the comfort of my home gym
in the house. I can go work out
whenever I want, though. Basketball
court, A basketball court.
Okay, that's dope.
It's like I can just whoop any time.
I don't have to drive to the Lifetime
Fitness. I ain't gotta boom boom-- I
like that.
Okay, that makes sense, then.
Vacations. I can't really sit here and.
Bro. I like that. Yeah, that makes
sense. From the space of.
I wish I had something for you, though.
I wish I had something dope. Like, I
don't.
I like that you don't, though.
I like. I like that you.
Are you sure I'm the jackass with the
stupid hobbies and the things like that
that I've gotten to.